[Music]
hey you guys welcome to another episode
of risk of fury I'm Kelsey cook and
today I'm joined by two very special
guests who are not on set yet and I've
never actually met them before I'm
joined by the comedy duo Danish and
O'Neill
it's Jeff dannis and Ryan O'Neal my
producer has told me at least three
times that I will not be harmed
which is very disturbing I don't know
what hey guys you can applaud and then
we expect applause thank you we know you
know who we are like you thank you nice
to meet you by the way
right hi I know Neil hi Ryan
jerm season hi hi isn't every season
germ season technically for me yes I'm
gonna take my medals oh yeah I think for
sound seriously don't but you know what
we won these four No please enlighten me
okay you've been had real deal here I'm
from your mullet I would say so that's
very authentic foosball
I'm leaving one medal on just to let you
know right here so a little reminder so
you know what you're dealing with have
you seen this is this problematic for
you at all no not at all you're the only
ones that we could fit in the car oh I
understand see the others for somebody
so good why do you so few trophies my
house cover like it's like you like six
okay wow they're nice they're nice
quality but like nice done they're not a
good image we play you're good ornaments
sure they're not the real deal
we want to be out of once for a
tournament what in the [ __ ] is happening
this is the weirdest thing that's ever
happened on the look at these let me
just get a little feel for the equipment
oh by the way before we sign off to have
this release we're gonna need a urine
sample here's ours yeah so if you could
get us one otherwise we won't let this
air cuz we only play with clean players
so yeah I'll give you this bottle finish
my water cuz I look pretty write it out
if you want to thank you that's the
height of this table
[Music]
I didn't bring a level so I'm just gonna
take your word for it the other thing is
we're not accusing the koban then why
did this we think that you may have done
some tomfoolery good yeah it's not pro
level but played on worse oh my god
we know you like gin to draw you a
little present thank you so much
we've watched all your game tape against
Josh wolf you said you'll drink gin and
if there's no chasers
you'll eat deli meat I chased it with
deli meat yeah but I don't see any
chasers here and we just happen to have
some oh yeah you put your money or your
deli meat here for any but your deli
meat where your mouth is also we watched
a lot of game tape but I got to be asked
whether you couldn't watch the whole
thing because your technique is sloppy
oh you think yeah don't think I know for
a fact Wow I watched it all I suffered
through it he said he couldn't he watch
it for the interviews mainly wow I am so
excited to destroy you guys I've never
been more excited to kick two grown
men's asses wearing is that a kitten
riding a shark yeah throwing up a
rainbow that's in right now it's back to
school yeah yeah everyone you play and
yourself includes no pageantry where's
the pageantry for the game we're trying
to get this all made into an Olympic
sport how are we gonna do it if people
just redress like you're gonna
substitute teach a health class yeah
we're dress we're taking the sport to
happy gilmore less yeah you want the
press talking about it here's what we're
gonna do every goal we're all gonna take
a shot and take a hit a little doobie
are you cool with that I if I lose I'll
Tim a shot at the end of the show is at
the end of the show the end of the show
and hit this doobie no I'm not gonna hit
the doobie that's are you
that's all you brother
[Music]
whenever you want to get started we're
totally dead wow I wasn't prepared today
for this I'm gonna go it's gonna be a
good time we play it with sudden swishes
we do line switches so do you drink your
pee you drink your pee Wow you gotta get
the nutrients back in sound a lot of
vitamins it's a lot of electrolytes in
their refrigerator you keep it warm oh
this this is room temperature that's the
way I like me you're by the way can I
inspect the ball you can I didn't bring
my ball monocle but absolutely eyeball
respect some balls get up closer we got
two of these yeah
nice full calf stretch that's faster but
thank you I'm just curious like what are
some of the top tournaments you guys
have been to Berlin 2012 World
Championship is a good one for you er
there we want a piece of the wall for
that one here yeah it gets crazy over
there hold on before I start playing I
got to get my gun yeah what is this for
the street ball we've been robbed lunch
plans so we've haven't done some robbing
as well but we should probably just put
that away
yeah we're good good hey get a beer from
somebody they're beers here let's make
two beers yeah
I will do a shot with you to start this
all off let's do it if you do it with me
I don't even like gin but yeah I'm game
what's your mom's name Cathy - Cathy -
Cathy hall-of-fame all of famer my dad's
in the whole thing by the way stuff it
yeah you eat the turkey first oh great
cute okay okay are you guys ready we're
ready wait how do you start start here
no no but I asked ready you say ready I
had to touch the ball - to mine I
usually have a third party count one two
three go yeah we could get that Rachel
would you mind one two three go wait
wait wait so weird
yeah we're not ready we'll tell you look
at me for a second let's do your thing
let's do ready okay okay Rachel we get a
foot work down how's that feel so far
left eyes Larry we sometimes will let
people get to 36 yeah and then we'll
start playing and we'll crush them
classic the dope and we're looking at
the dope right now all right Rachel get
give the countdown we don't need it it's
for when our opponent is oh okay so you
guys just start whenever you I count
down one we okay yeah what did we go
[Music]
timeout this happens a lot when we put
[Applause]
first goal was a fluke just take your
time no rush here okay so you can't hey
what are you doing you can't touch it
you touch it the game is tainted you
blow in it I'm getting a good better eye
on the ball here stop with the sexual
innuendos there we go there we go come
on baby come on baby come on baby
we're asexual so we appreciate any sex
talk yeah maybe locker room talk to the
locker room do you guys have a reason
for you playing D and you playing
offense like is there a strategy in that
my last name starts with D so bring it
home bring it home baby bring it home
hey red you had a clear shot bring it
all baby there you go I don't want
scored that's how weakness is bring it
back forget back maybe I'm opening the
floor for you Walker we did that
intentionally ourselves yeah we like a
3-0 deficit a lot you guys are gonna
have that big comeback you're talking
about I would I would maybe go thank you
oh she was too busy yappin yeah
oh man you might want to stop yapping I
had an erection oh look at that oh look
who's toying with you now oh whoa oh
look who's got the ball
oh we're get down here bring it back
down come on come on she's nervous I can
sense it
she's stalling trying to run out the
clock Oh Tony Meola old school world
come let her win the first game classic
Danish and O'Neill strategy we're gonna
do things to make it easier for you to
beat me yeah well okay sounds sounds
counterintuitive don't do anything on
our behalf because hey you sure you guys
don't need some help it's I just beat
you five oh don't you think you want
like a little bit of help
oh yeah cops let's go okay see you guys
come pick a ball what did you get got a
five okay okay I got two so what's gonna
happen now is that every five seconds
you guys have to switch spots and every
five seconds I have to close my eyes for
five seconds so it'll be my eyes will be
open for five seconds and then closed
for five over five so a lot of [ __ ] can
happen in those five seconds of my eyes
are closed we're used to switching every
three seconds yeah throw us off yeah but
only two seconds off we trained our
whole life with our eyes closed that's
why we had LASIK today and we still came
into play okay you're like Bane this is
more than the dark this is important to
us all right you guys want me to start
the five seconds point fold it or not
blindfold oh no it looks like a small
brazier how can I know anything about
that because I'm asexual but I have seen
commercials there's a cat bra I was
gonna say if you guys I see I want to
start with you I'm gonna go buy okay
I'm going behind okay okay move okay
football if you watch football you know
this move okay we ready I know you're
[ __ ] with me I'm not not at all I
hear you over here what do you Stevie
Wonder you say
you become Mattoon you've been fine for
one second one two three go
yeah I knew I [ __ ] knew it I knew it I
knew it I knew it there's no I'm not
starting with it on now ask me to do you
really feel good about taking a point
yes 1 2 3 1 2 3
Brian's got it - this really does even
the odds I see why you do it for the
show this is some [ __ ] ok ready 1 2
3 that's the only way I'm gonna get
points if I do it in five seconds ready
1 2 3 go 1 2 switch it on don't let it
go there we go there we go come on get
it down there get it down there get it
down there baby come on
[Music]
[Applause]
that's not for you this is for me Wow
okay one two three go
[Music]
all tied up I like the drama dr.
Bernstein said we were fine to play oh
no no I didn't count it I think we
should count it
I think we course she would advantage I
think the first two points were you guys
literally just throwing the ball in the
hole so I'm gonna take that you know
this isn't the Kelsey I know from the TV
show yeah wait one two three go go go go
go go move down there oh oh what's that
having little trouble probably
[Applause]
close game what happens so what happens
now is that we're gonna play two ball
when you guys lose cuz you will lose you
guys have to lady and [ __ ] style a dog
bone you have to eat a dog bone to the
middle what happens if you lose
we don't bother setting up a punishment
for me because I won't what no but I
think we should set up yeah you have to
smoke that whole joint if I lose to you
guys in two ball I'll smoke that whole
joint while you sing and Chumbawamba
something one two three oh look it looks
like we're scoring now watch out get
that one back here bring it back down
bring it back down bring it back out
yeah there we go there we go looks like
nobody wash and dry balls are Gabe man
we're playing with house 3 bang we go
back down it pass money spitter
I'm gonna go spin she's gonna discredit
it wait you guys don't at the car wash
here we go Oh bring it down baby bring
it down no no don't let her do that
don't let her do that
did she [ __ ] with the one that threw me
off my game she's doing all kinds of
psychological tormenting don't you want
to earn that one feel good about that
one I've earned it earned it the hard
way there's a little off what's there
buys a lot of damage here get that look
that I have a guy in a guy totally do
your field he works or Alf's parking
lots at the grocery store
once you go watch out oh [ __ ] no oh look
at that
Oh baby we're used to juggling way more
balls so ready one two three go okay
there we go up bring it down bring it
down
hold on hold on ere we go bring bring it
to me baby Oh classic spin have a little
trouble getting through that defensive
line yeah looks like you aren't here
look at that ball just wasting away in
Margaritaville Oh watch out oh we scored
on ourselves that's okay just jam my
thumb there medic technically I scored
on him just to see if he had his
reflexes yeah I apologize I let you down
down there
you guys want to maybe switch because
I'm right now it's three zero so this
maybe isn't working maybe you want to
only switch sides
have you ever played on this side
there's a beer that urine the ham and
urine so I'm gonna try the goal Oh guys
and now you're up front are you ready
for this we've never played black before
it's frontline man there's an odd
adjustment your focus on this is from
[Laughter]
you guys go get spin who doesn't wear
spinners always happen
oh man so what is that is that a whole
game jerem season sure season I'll shake
this is turkey on it though okay where
are these dog bones before we get that
dog bone you want me to shock on this
wheat into your mouth not really
okay it's a little foreplay before the
the big makeout we've known each other
for years
you don't think we've done way worse
than this no what the [ __ ] you could do
we took a shower this morning together
yeah to help save the environment and
just to create synergy well you only
have little ones so we've got a little
more a huge one we've got a little one
which means you're gonna get intimate
real fast not sexual okay ready
get it oh that was weak you've got a
ladyandtramp it you got a munch munch
munch kiss
we ate this because I don't hate it
another one yeah so these actually taste
okay to you guys cuz most comics come on
and eat them and throw up yeah most
comics are [ __ ] we want do like this
yeah and then like you'd say you
psychopath yeah you're coming home ready
to go insane behavior are you do you
want to put your gun back on for the
bike wait you feel it's so aggressively
because I'm like this I've never done
anything like this with your tongue as
an asexual you even know we do it
fantastic I feel fantastic good all
right plug it where people can find you
guys well as you know well from the
Danish turn O'Neill podcast yes check us
out on Danish no Neil on Twitter - no
Neil on Instagram and if anyone wants
three foosballs
on eBay look up Danish 69 at eBay calm
yeah can you Wow oh my god right
okay my mom's here to pick it out you
guys could follow me on instagram at
casa good comedy go to my website Kelsey
code comm are also called Kelsey cook
combo with the EE at the end of it for
all our comedy you like some tales
subscribe to self helpless podcast
please subscribe to the all things
comedy youtube channel go watch all the
past episodes bye by erisa fury t-shirt
and we will see you guys next week thank
you guys for watching another episode of
wrists of fury be sure to pick up your
official Larisa fury shirts they are
buttery soft they feel like dolphin skin
there's lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
[Music]
you